encore là et on va accueillir tous
dessus de kaka qui vient pour vous il
s'appelle rno c'est parti
applaudissements polis tous saluent
pavillon cibc salut couilles de vieux
alors vous venez de voir ce que je sais
que vous adorez korda d'orly mais c'est
exactement je viendrai je me pointe
attention et je suspecte des glaçons
attention c'est du faux quand je suis
venu avec les sacoches j'avais après
t'as intérêt à prévoir la motobécane
alors on va jouer avec vous quoi et bien
sûr des doléances et corps vous à pernod
moi je m'appelle brno est lui assez
michel belpech je vous déconseille de
passer aux toilettes derrière lui vous
allez essayer de trouver des animateurs
télé qu'il exècre ira se servent
actuellement mon grand je suis pointé
ans libère alors est-ce une petite
galère question
on est en train de sonner sans d'une
bouteille de rougegoutte avec mon ami au
comptoir d'un côté sur les petits doutes
quant à une bande de loubards qui avec
sa part à coups de chaînes de vélo
d'heure en ponot je te passe les détails
ma fille est une beigne
j'ai fait une mandale ma fille
tchétchène et du fils aymon fuite alors
merci jouer chez vous également avec
nous avant d'accueillir kabyle koval
bien sûr et bien sûr on joue tu trouves
pas de problème
tu perds tu te prends un ramponneau
entre l'ès 5 élèves attention unique
dans la musique
l'animateur qui pourrait n'être qu'un
ses élites il présente enquête
actualités sur d8
eux qui pisse l'amour en bidon de 5
litres tout le monde ici la belgique est
il allé chic hôtel mont blanc qui doit
se les prendre au tipex à tous les
protéas l'ocha belle avec un tampon gex
il est tellement tout près et on dirait
qui sort de sa vous
il a le même après shampoing que de là
où ils allaient jouer tellement routier
est en photo chez prouve
selon mercy locaux sur lot c'est juste
un petit pas de danse et court on
n'avait pas trop le temps exact stoehr
précédent alors moscou cette route qui
j'aime autant dire vas-y tu la prends
pour moi tu veux pas te causer des
dégâts
et rappelle que corneille sera en
concert à la cigale sont guy lagache le
voilà un an exactement
c'est quoi la deuxième deuxième chanson
on cherche une starlette attention ça au
roi hier près du rivage ou prévient y
aura de quoi s'en taper les murs sur le
front sur celle on y va c'est parti
attention musique
c'est une faute il starlette est une
sacrée paire de lolo elle a dit si t'as
pas de sens - dans des halos c'est sûr
c'est pas un prix nobel qu'on respecte
la voir chez pilou qu'elle induit un
ravioli mais quand je vois son pétard
j'ai envie d'être la ficelle de son
string léopard avec les coutures en
dentelle par lesquelles s'est fait
refaire les miches avec d'hubert 13 par
une bande de maçon super balèze
moi je la regarde sur nrj 12 en lâchant
deux ou trois paires l'eau
use ses cadeaux sono et
il est où vous avez trouvé
vu la réaction de mathieu je pensais
nabil afkir avila les boulots
elle a soulevé en faire une dernière
pour la route ça c'est cadeau je vais
chez vous
lui c'est un chroniqueur qui est sur ce
plateau toujours d'accord pour une
fricassée de museau 30 in à poil sous
son futal avec son poids thierry moreau
pour lula dit cet animal pour lundi à
paris dans tous les clubs et qui est
super v ip mais moi que ça te vider 6
par et de l'émission il y aurait plus de
questions auxquelles tiers c'est le
fantasme de toutes les ménagères
je suis sûr que même dans son cercueil
ils voient toujours comme un chevreuil
solo
j'ai pas trouvé mieux ouais si je peux
me permettre
il faut retravailler le solo pour la
passionnerait c'est dommage mais c'est
pas mal aussi pourtant bien sympa lui
oui ça c'est michel delpech voulait que
de passer d'un lieu au cabinet alors est
ce que vous avez trouvé
ouais c'est monsieur jean michel bayle
ouais c'est lui moi que tout le monde le
connaît c'est le loup blanc riez connu
comme le complète quentinois